moment to eat the water and you lifted
yourself in buoyancy and you're floating
this is like you're flying
then it's freedom that's what it's for
me that amount of rule power
it was difficult it was really difficult
knowing that you weren't able to serve
again I think that was harder for me
than not being able to walk again and
appreciate what you do have make the
base with what you've got because you
never know when you when you when you're
not gonna have it anymore
people visit missile they pretend to be
very cooped up and protected and the
moment you exposed to give them some of
that exposure the amount of
self-confidence they gained from being
on the earth in the water without anyone
touching them or pushing them or holding
them it's a different experience
the only as limited as you Larry Southie
you don't have to go and sit and give up
when life gives you a disability Claude
you can still go on and do things in a
different way and you're not alone there
there's a lot of people going through
the similar thing that's what you're all
about change the reading experience
you